you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's program we hear from the
north sea oil and gas workers
forced to pay for training they can't
afford or risk losing work as the uk
moves away from fossil fuels to
renewable energy
political point scoring or a way to
protect a world heritage site
the row over classing the great barrier
reef as
in danger heats up and how your home
could become a mini power station to
help the uk
reach its climate targets
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
where we track the changes that are
happening to our world right now
and we meet those coming up with the
solutions well as countries around the
world attempt to reduce emissions from
fossil fuels
the energy sector needs to undergo a
huge transformation
with oil and gas making way for
renewables
the north sea transition deal agreed by
the government in march
aims to help workers in those sectors
retrain
and move into clean energy but that is
not necessarily happening
a survey of more than 600 north sea oil
and gas workers
found that workers themselves are having
to pay
nearly 2 000 pounds a year in training
costs
nearly two-thirds said that in the past
two years their employer contributed
nothing financially to their retraining
and nearly three-quarters of those
surveyed are contractors without
guaranteed employment
opportunities and 94 said that they
would support a solution in the form of
an
offshore passport which would
effectively license all
accredited workers to work offshore in
any sector
our climate correspondent lisa holland
reports now from aberdeen
when the weather's good there's a
regular flow of helicopters ferrying oil
and gas workers from aberdeen airport
to rigs across the north sea
at a nearby pub the relief of getting
back to shore
is clear but change the subject to
people's futures and finding green jobs
and nobody wants to speak openly for
fear of being blacklisted within the
industry
they are really really angry everyone is
really angry in the oil field at the
minute
this man has worked in oil and gas for
18 years
when i started it was good times but i
know a lot of people have lost their
jobs
how much help do you feel is being given
to people in the oil and gas industry to
find a new job
i haven't personally seen any help like
that and nobody i've ever spoken to in
my time offshore
has ever said they're getting help that
uncertainty is felt across aberdeen
a city built around the oil boom of the
70s
after 42 years in oil and gas norman is
close to retirement
and for that reason agreed to show his
identity
he says he never imagined such
uncertainty
i want to finish my working career
working i don't want to finish like this
this is
not good for anyone but
for a young guy and he stopped these i
would say it would be
pretty devastating in the harbour oil
and gas supply ships await instructions
wind farms at sea point to a future of
renewables
which nobody quite knows when and how
will overtake the city's past
lisa holland sky news aberdeen
well let's bring in deidre mickey now
chief executive of
oil and gas uk deirdre good to talk to
you
you represent an industry that's
effectively in
managed decline and the workers we were
hearing from there
clearly don't have any confidence that
anyone's looking out for them
yeah good afternoon sam um i think it's
a really interesting report
um that greenpeace and um friends of
their put out today
because uh you know and welcome it
because it acknowledges the role
that this sector and the workforce have
to play in delivering a successful
energy transition
and i think the thing that wasn't didn't
come out of your report was how much
change is going on in the sector you
know many of our
companies are already into all the other
energies like hydrogen
carbon capture storage and renewables as
well as oil and gas
and it's really important that they do
move into all these sectors because we
are going to need oil and gas for years
to come
and so the skills and the expertise that
we have today
in our sector will be absolutely crucial
to these
emerging energy sectors going forward
and deity how would this offshore
passport work
so so one of the things that the report
speaks to is removing the barriers so
that people can
move seamlessly between the different
sectors
and that's something you absolutely
support that principle
whether it's a passport or whether it's
it's another means of aligning
in terms of different standards and
approaches
you know that's something that we need
to work on but the principle
is absolutely right but we should be
reducing as many barriers as we can
so that people can work in oil and gas
they can move into
hydrogen they can move into offshore
wind and that they can do that
relatively seamlessly and relatively
easily
did you make it good to talk to you
thank you
thanks very much well in today's other
climate news
the uk's sustainable aviation alliance
has set
new co2 targets in a bid to reach net
zero by 2050.
airlines airports and other service
providers have promised to reduce or
indeed offset
the sector's net emissions by 15 by 2030
and by 40 in 2040. however those targets
will have to be met by offsetting
schemes and technology
which is not yet fully commercialized
smart traffic lights which tell
motorists how long is left until they
change to red
could be introduced in england to reduce
co2
emissions a trial of the new technology
found vehicle emissions were cut by more
than a quarter
as it minimised the number of
unnecessary stops
it also led to a 17 reduction in
nitrogen oxide levels from engines
which is linked to poor air quality
gabon has become the first country in
africa to be rewarded for
lowering its co2 emissions the un's
central african forest initiative has
paid the country
17 million dollars for reducing
greenhouse gas emissions
in 2016 and 2017. gabon says the money
will be invested into
low-carbon strategies which can help
reduce co2 levels and protect
biodiversity
and the duchess of cambridge has visited
the natural history museum to hear about
its urban
nature project the project aims to help
communities across the uk to understand
the importance of nature
and find practical solutions to protect
our planet's future
well during her visit the duchess joined
local school children in the museum's
wildlife garden
and took part in activities including
spider-making and
storytelling now the great barrier reef
is one of the world's natural wonders
and its coral reefs play a crucial role
in our environment
but now the un's cultural body unesco
wants it added to a list of
endangered world heritage sites due to
the impact of climate change
australia has reacted angrily to the
recommendation after it has spent
years trying to keep the reef off that
list
and its government says it will oppose
the plan
here's everything you need to know about
the row
[Music]
this decision was flawed clearly there
were politics behind it
clearly those politics have subverted
a proper process
[Music]
i will stand up in any community and i
do
and say that we have the best managed
reef in the world
[Music]
the values are definitely in danger so
from that perspective yes
the world heritage property should be
listed in danger it's not a permanent
listing
and many properties have come off the
endangered list once they can
show that they have addressed the
concerns that have been raised by the
committee
now big changes are going to be needed
to our homes if the uk
is to reach its target of net zero
emissions by 2050
according to a new report published by
good energy
well it found that in the next 30 years
13 and a half
billion homes are going to need to have
rooftop solar panels
more than 80 of heating will need to be
electrified that's rather than using
natural gas
and homes should have battery walls to
allow residents to store and
use renewable energy when they need it
and driverless electric vehicles will
need to become the norm
using technology to send power back to
the grid
in times of high demand well joining me
now is juliette davenport
founder of good energy juliet good to
talk to you
it's clear isn't it that households need
to do
their bit but even most new builds don't
have any of those elements yet
completely and it's i mean that what the
reports lays out is that we've
investigated
looking at taking renewables out to the
nation
and what else do you need and what is
clear is the housing stock in the uk
really lags behind the investments that
we've made seen in other european
countries
so it's under insulated it doesn't we
we don't really consider it as part of
our energy infrastructure
whereas actually we could turn it into a
benefit where we could see
consumers generating their own power and
being an active part of the
the the power network by sending power
back as you said from
either their electric vehicle or storage
in their own homes
julia when we look at our power mix that
percentage that comes
from renewables needs to be much much
higher
doesn't it and what kind of
infrastructure do we need in place to
support
that change so i think you touched on
earlier on offshore wind is going to be
a really important part of this mix so
making sure that we've got
an industry the skills and technology to
be able to deliver offshore wind
and the power systems to be able to to
bring that in from offshore
but we're also going to see um from from
our analysis
we see some larger scale solar going in
so again we're going to need
the capability of taking power
delivering power locally
we're going to need to see uh geothermal
so geothermal is a technology
there's not much use but actually we've
got abundant sources in the uk and we're
already beginning to see
places like the eden center explore for
geothermal
and tidal tidal is going to be a really
important technology
something that as an island we have a
lot more than most other countries do
oh it's so interesting talking to you
juliet davenport thank you
thank you lovely to talk to you well
that is all for today coming up on
tomorrow's show
the story of britain's acid tar lagoons
polluting local land with toxic liquid
you can see that at the same time here
on
sky news hope to see you then